they think oh I'm broken I have this
trauma my man is gonna fix me or my
woman is gonna fix me no way they speak
to their friends and their friends are
like oh my husband did this and they're
thinking oh my gosh why is my husband
not doing it it comes at a cost where
marriages are ending because of this
high expectations as men you guys have
to also Implement your own boundaries
and you shouldn't feel bad for doing
that most of the times these women don't
work and they don't have their own
income coming on coming in and they're
completely reliant on their husband and
he knows this and he uses this as a
leverage over her yeah and his money is
your money yeah so if he that doesn't
stand that when they finally break up
and they leave each other there's
they're not co-parenting they want I'm
having a child today no you're not yeah
you're doing this no you're not and I
know a lot of brothers said oh you know
what women say that they want these
things but realistically they don't are
women actually practicing these things
for them to attract that kind of man and
to to the guys out there you need to do
the healing to the girls out there you
need to do the healing a Gucci bag is
not going to heal that nice shoes are
not going to heal that um public dates
first thing they ask me is how much do
you earn what's your job but in a nicer
way right they ask me how much are you
earning and stuff not if I'm practicing
yeah some men believe that you know me
doing the bare minimum and the bare
minimum means provide protect and that's
it no affection No Love No Mercy no
nothing that if two parents are not
happy it's more detrimental to
well but do I not buy you clothes look
look at the tone not hey I buy you
clothes I own you no no no but do I not
buy you clothes but do I not work hard
for our family I'm saving up for a
holiday does that apply to that man no
it doesn't reminded then that's
fine is important try
to
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sar for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another episode of
the bit of Truth show um and we are here
as you guys know talking about variety
of topics um that uh is pertaining to
the breakdown of the family unit and
also different aspects different topics
uh that will insh benefit you guys at
home our aim is to preserve the marital
unit as an attack left right center and
we just want to understand opposite
gender better and vice versa for then
inshallah me personally I learned so
many things on the show from our sisters
and I incorporate it into uh my life
with my wife um and I learn a lot it
helps me it helps my marriage and I hope
so that same is with you guys who are
watching at home inshallah and yes um
before I start I want to praise Allah
subhana tala the most merciful the most
just all Praises glory and belong to him
um guys you have the bitter buzzers make
the most out of it nobody's really used
it today uh but if you have to use it
it's a buzzer if you disagree with one
of uh you know the sisters or sisters
disagree with the sisters or the
brothers disagree with the brothers you
have one and a half minutes and you can
talk nobody can interrupt you uh let's
not back bite slander we know anyways um
and that's it yes today's topic is a
very interesting one I personally
believe it's going to be 25 episodes
this is the first one uh it's uh what
woman want in a man um yes we are going
to be here probably uh for quite a bit
of time uh probably we will leave and
they or carry on talking I'm joking so
in a night show our honorable sisters
are here may Allah bless and preserve
them in some of them came from
Manchester sister
Parina yeah that's that's your name so
you came from Manchester sister ha
sister haa may Allah bless you inshah
we're in London from London sister Hala
from Manchester and sister Amir she's a
regular may she has great input
alhamdulillah sometimes she does get a
bit angry uh but she has good intentions
may Allah bless her inshah um this time
today she didn't come with her husband
uh please come next time I miss you Aki
my my my buddy and we've got Mike may
Allah bless him in and we've got brother
anas anas is actually may Allah bless
him he this bit Tru show it happens one
of the reasons is because of him may
Allah bless him and he's got so much uh
input he he he will put inshah and he's
one thing I love about him is his his he
talks less unlike me I talk too much but
may Allah bless him inah for the efforts
that he puts and we've got brother Mii
who's new inshallah may Allah bless him
going to get you married soon don't
worry uh brother Anis as well sisters if
you're Wes please get in contact to the
bit truth gmail.com why ald promoting
here in it so let's go to the sisters
sisters what do you guys want in a man
uh we know you have a big list if you
can drop it down to three it'll be very
appreciated other than that the floor is
you guys let's start with who would like
to start first go on sister in tell us
what does a woman or what do you
personally look for in a husband or a
man so
I don't like to look at this from a
black and white perspective I believe
that um I I don't have the right to
speak for all women but personally I
think that safety is Key Safety is very
very important for me to be able to feel
safe around my partner to feel authentic
to feel that I'm able to be myself that
I don't have to tiptoe around him um you
know just no physical harm no abuse I
think that is key with any kind of
relationship even with anyone Rel dad
brother and so I would say the second
thing is Free Will you know um I would
appreciate if my husband understands and
he's aware of the law which
is which is Free Will which means that I
am a free woman in
who has rights who is a servant of Allah
and not basically a a receipt or like my
own um and who understands the spiritual
contract which is a between one another
um the third thing would be um that he
has a leadership personality so he takes
theing his masculine he's a provider
he's wise he's patient someone that I
can be in a team with so it's not a t
like the Quran
says the whole reason why men and women
have this tug of war is because Shan is
not allowing us to um be in that
paradise Allah
says so we here to actually Implement
and practice what it's like to live
Paradise on Earth so that inshallah we
can take it to the fourth would be
obviously respect so he respects he's
very respectful in his communication he
respects my boundaries respects my
dreams and
Ambitions
[Music]
um yeah so he respects my um dreams and
Ambitions and you know respects my
family respects me we can have an honest
and open discussion um and I would say A
Grateful man I think a man who's
grateful is will never ever be poor in
his life um Allah
says and all the messengers for them to
reach to have reached the level of
Prophecy Allah
says and the opposite of is so if he's
someone who does or doesn't appreciate
what I do and you know all of that I
think that kind of can throw him off as
being someone ungrateful and that can
give him a kind of a like
um you know full mindset um but this
doesn't mean that I'm expecting all of
these things and I'm not going to do
anything it has to be mitual I have to
reflect that so everything that I've
said I have to be respectful I have to
also give him his free will if he wants
to get married I give him the right if
he wants to for example say I'm going to
do this and it's all about compromise at
the end of the day um and I think one um
important thing as well is he doesn't
have an high ego so he doesn't
discriminate women doesn't look down on
women
um finds it very very easy to say that
I'm sorry you know what I was wrong in
that I apologize and we can have that
kind of and
said
and yeah I think that's I would say the
basics and the foundations and their
core values like these things are
non-negotiable I think anyone whatever
race whatever gender whatever age you
are this is something that you practice
and looking at back all the the topics
you you lot spoke about earlier
I think if people focus on core
values that's the main thing like that's
the the fundamental and then you can
build off that foundation and then after
it comes obviously compatibility comes
um like um intimacy and and uh uh like
chemistry and all of that which is I
would say like the I thing on the cake
but yeah perfect okay sister Pine what
would you
say a woman looks for in a man or or
yourself personally or your friends the
people that what's the what's the
general discussion at hand like what's
this say that's lacking in you know
these
men okay um so
like like K said uh I'm not speaking for
every woman out there because every
woman is different we're different let
me emphasize we're different we all have
different needs um but personally for me
being is number one um if you're a man
of God God you'll do everything else
right um if you're not a man of God
you're not going to do anything right so
that means respect everything everything
on that line and then next is you have
to be a leader and what I mean by that
is provide protect and that's all I want
and
then because I'm someone who's quite
ambitious that I have ambitious goals
that aligns with my Dean I need a
guy who is not only like you can pray
you can do all of that but I want you to
have a higher goal that is an worship
you live through it and and youris
through it um and lastly I just want to
love me and care about me give me your
time and attention that's that's all I
want Mah okay sister Hala it's like she
read my
mind I think I think she read every
woman's mind you know she said it in
order as well you know God-fearing
leadership and loving I don't care about
anything else like this is
just that's
is that's the fairy tale side of things
I'm joking no it's true like I do agree
with a lot of um what they said
especially haa like you described it so
beautifully um for me I think it's
important for a man to have discipline
dis
then leaks into your faith you know
having the ability to lead the children
to prayer um you know lead myself also
to remembering Allah um but for me it's
more than just the little surface things
that they said like for me I I do want
romance I want my husband to be able to
to show that romantic side to him you
know I like like uh
spontaneousness like let's go out let's
go yeah spontaneity I never say that
word properly um you know uh I I do like
to be you know wine and DED not with the
wine because we're Muslim but I do like
that experience I'm not going to sit
here and act like you know oh I just
want to be praying with my husband
that's lies I know a lot of women that
will say I want him to be in the de yes
we do we know that that's the basics
don't marry me if you don't have that
okay but you know we do we as women we
do like to go we like to be whined and
DED we like gifts here and there I like
flowers I want you to do the sunnas with
me like the romantic sunnas with me that
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to do I like those things
you know I want my husband to to be able
to to exhibit strength you know and be
able to motivate me as well like not to
just I don't know for me anyway
personally I don't like mediocrity I
don't like to live a mediocre life I
like to have fun I like to be reminded
to be healthy I you know I'm in that
position myself where I've just had a
baby or whatever and I'm I want to get
back into shape I want my husband to be
able to motivate me to do these things
you know I want my husband to be able to
defend me if if if needs be and to be
honest I'm a bit of a hotthead myself I
would defend my husband if if somebody
comes crazy to my husband I'm going to
defend my husband as well you know just
that ride or die mentality I'm here for
my husband and I want him to be here for
me as well so yeah I do love the the
dean and everything but I think that's a
given when you um when you marry
somebody I think that should be really
taken into consideration before you
marry somebody you know can I say
something you can't just be can I
someone who's not praying yeah you know
what I'm noticed whilst you're speaking
um because I'm just listening to
understand you um everything you're
actually saying falls into those
categories think about it leadership
absolutely being um love like romance it
could be every form of love there is
there people have different Love
Languages yeah yeah exactly that's why I
said for me personally like my that's
what I like like I want that I want but
you know why I say women are different
because said different things yeah yeah
it's true but okay interesting I know if
I let you guys carry on you're going to
be here for a long time um I just say
yes I want to experience this with my
husband so I want this in my husband
right he wants to like rent not rent but
own a boat with me and just go like out
to the Sea for a couple of months I
would do that
why not why not it's it's it's you know
what it is it's that's Ro like you were
saying about until you get
seasick no no insh may Allah Grant you a
Jenna and may Allah Grant you a husband
who owns a boat
inshallah yeah yeah why not yeah no if
not I'll get it myself and I'll find it
no no no he should buy it for his sister
this is this is Islam he's a protector
and provider so he needs to make sure
we're looking for any brothers outside
in if you have a boat you got before
that though inshah you know about as
well but they have the the of
of you know um beautiful yes so
interesting but that's very good that's
very good that's very interesting but
the point is this do you not agree I
don't know brother tell me do you not
think sometimes sisters say things they
want but they they they do not want that
like some I feel like sisters say like I
want this this this can you give an
example for example I want a man that
will wake me up for f i want a man that
is on the dean Etc deep down they don't
really it's not that deep for them they
want the d so I'm just I'm just put out
I'm not saying that I'm just saying um
please correct me um and brothers would
you would you agree that sometimes
sisters come with like yeah I want this
I want that maybe from what they see on
TV or like saying in's time but what I
will say now that I've got the chance to
speak because I don't know how many
chances I'm going to have on this one
but um none all of all of what you had
to say was very realistic like I can't
actually argue any ofe one of the one of
the big is spontaneity one thing I've
actually realized yet is that ladies
love spontaneity cuz it's like they like
a surprise they like okay we're going
out here but yeah and they and they want
to go that's just that's just something
I've realized that they really like so
spontaneity big one get a bit boring
after a while that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying they just think
it's okay to just sit at that's what I'm
saying for men you have I think I think
because men cuz men work cuz men work
and they're used to a mundane life
they're not thinking about how they're
wife is feeling cuz they're used to a
mundane life they're okay with it they
they're working so like they're not
thinking about what's going on with
their wife and then they're
surprised like you like darling I'm
bored and it's like what do you mean
you're bored like I'm you know I'm
earning money and this yeah but I'm
bored so spontaneity and the romance sh
has is all throughout the relationship
I'm not you know I'm not old I'm not old
enough to know like the wisdom behind
very successful marriages but I'd say
that's a big thing of spontaneity 100% I
think um everything you guys said is
correct but ideally that's what you'd
want in a partner right IDE that's the
person I'd want to be too in general but
I think the expectation for our
generation is too high I'll be honest
with you I'm not in a single man have
could do what what you guys want I their
expectation is too high me I'm not
saying it's a bad thing let me let me be
clear sorry go on unfinished yeah let me
let me let me be clear yeah so when I
say spontaneity that doesn't have to
cost anything and that's what men so you
see how you've translated that as women
when we're like we just want your time
that could be a walk by the canal that
could be a walk you
know near the London Eye you know it
doesn't have to cost and that's what men
think you know okay there are some women
out there who who do not live or do not
want to live within their means and they
look at social media and then they want
that and above I don't know what else
they want but yeah I agree with you that
it can that's why communication is key I
think um yeah it's good points what you
said but I think more often than not
just from personal experience um women
are more materialistic than men right so
I'll be honest when I've gone on like
when I sping to women aw you know going
on these like um public dates first
thing they ask me is how much do you
earn what's your job but in a nicer way
right ask me how much you earning and
stuff not if I'm practicing so I think
why did they ask you that say again why
do they ask you that because we're on a
date no because if you if you get her
pregnant yeah so you saying they're
saying it from a safety perspective it's
it's true stability thing it's true
women women they tend to look for that
you're right but this is like hidden
it's stability it goes It goes back to
your hypergamous nature as a woman you
look for a man who is stronger fitter
who earns more who knows more than you
who's a leader
because no no no you're right you're
right no it's true but today's today's
woman tell us if if we're wrong here
today's women are not thinking about if
I have a child that they're talking
about your luxury what luxury lifestyle
you're going to give to me and the thing
is we talked about spontane spontaneity
spontaneity need hijab in the building
yeah okay the slob of the gion yeah
anyways so the point here is this yeah
is that you said it doesn't come at Cost
you're right it doesn't come at a cost
for example to be spontaneous like you
know I try to incorporate that in my
marriage as well and by the way give a
disclaimer before people think Ali and
his marriage is so amazing me and my
wife have CS the drive by yeah trust me
you need to dodge bullets yeah yeah no
no no you know I have to say this
because I don't want to give a false
reality of people think like my marriage
look my marriage ups and down sometimes
it's a mad thing bro but it's a part of
marriage that's the reason why I'm
giving I have to tell you guys the Downs
so I can tell you the highs so sometimes
yes like spontaneous things boom we're
going to go here she doesn't even know
you get what I'm trying to say it's good
it can be done I try my best to do to
the best of my ability when but it can
come at a cost how there there are women
who are ending their marriages because
um I don't feel something in my stomach
the flipping Lil does that mean
butterflies yeah I don't feel I don't
know there's something missing so so so
when we talk about it comes at Cost
because sisters have this high
expectations they don't even know what
exactly it is they speak to their
friends and their friends are like oh my
husband did this and they're thinking oh
my gosh why is my husband not doing it
it comes at a cost where marriages are
ending because of this high expectations
would you not agree that these these
these realities because imagine you have
a husband who's not spontaneous just the
GU just not spontaneous there are women
who end marriages because of this yeah
but this is why I think being humble is
very important expect to die tomorrow
that's a fact you don't know you're
going to be here for tomorrow right so I
feel like being humble should be the Bas
line like you shouldn't
overexp and I think it's kind of selfish
as well if you are putting that pressure
on your husband like I want to go to the
Moon next week you know and you have to
take me there like come on and for and
for and and how how how as men how would
we tell our wives you need to you need
to stay like you need to not State Sor
you need to uh be more How would how can
we tell you politely you know one thing
I would say is number one thing that
we're so we women we listen to words
we're like hyperfocused it doesn't
matter about anything else we're hyper
focused on what you say and how you
saying um so let's say you're saying
that but don't ever accuse her don't
ever say you this and you that instead
you should say like I feel like I feel
like what was your point um it's okay no
it's okay it's okay how how can how can
you politely tell your wife tell uh your
wife you should be more humble more
often okay so first first you need to
single can you stop comparing me to
other men and stop Mak making me feel as
if I'm not good enough why don't you do
this oh why do you do that this thing
halima's husband has done how do we
communicate that because now you're
coming with an expectation that you got
of TV or Disneyland and now you want to
incorporate how can we communicate to
our wives this is making me feel
uncomfortable you're putting pressures
on me I feel like I'm not good enough
husband so what I would say is sit her
down like gently smile always have a
smile in on your face uh before you
before you even start speaking just tell
her oh you look beautiful today or
something like that um you're going to
get her excited um and then and then you
start speaking I feel like you know I
feel a
bit something to do with I feel like I'm
not being listened to you see that's the
thing all the things we're talking about
like Salah it has a methodology of how
to be meaning marriage yourself is act
of worship so conducting yourself
learning about before marriage
pre-marriage meaning for example how to
conduct for example like a football team
there has to although it's a team sport
it's a team just the individuals have to
do their basis before work before after
work all that type of stuff meaning that
two broken individuals are repe this
very very importantly because my
generation is that they think oh I'm
broken I have this trauma my man is
going to fix me or my woman is going to
fix me no way you don't know you don't
know how things change yes maybe maybe
not now that's what I'm saying going
back to the Salah Point look as children
we taught how to pray like this like
this for example now taking that to a
marriage when you're for example we have
this notion in the Muslim Community in
this 21st century everyone wants to be
knowledge everyone wants to get that
back everyone want to get in terms of
the marriage in of husband or wife but
they don't want to do the works in terms
of themselves inwards meaning how to be
a human when you shouldn't speak how you
should speak when to raise your voice as
a Muslim yes you can be angry yes you
should restrain your voice at times yes
your woman folk or the woman around you
you have to let them speak that's one of
the things emotional intelligence look
I'm going to be very blunt okay there
some men see if their sisters get raped
some of them look they'll tell their
sisters you can get married tomorrow
that's that's the lack of emotional
intelligence they have imagine that you
have that much emotional intelligence
that you're saying to your sister get
married the next day Subhan Allah you
know a woman who gets raped you have to
you have to actualize this that she
might not get married ever again that's
a real possibility um it's a fact Allah
Allah might have you know tested him
with that and may Allah re reveal all
the relieve all the women who go through
this because it's a reality meaning that
so I just want to end this that working
on yourself before marriage knowing
yourself is very important because you
know because we all have something in
here when someone says something you
know that hit me that part my character
is very important like some of us might
shy away from it saying I'm not going to
work on that because of my ego my mom or
my dad you know I'm going to I'm going
to St like this no you're supposed to
change as a Muslim as a Muslim you're
supposed to change this this Narrative
of my mom of my culture sorry sorry as
as a Muslim you have the highest
expectation is Allah and his and
his meaning that obey Allah and his uh
and his messenger at the at the highest
levels constantly consistently at your
pace meaning you look work yourself on a
consistent basis look rights and
responsibilities yes my man wants to be
this I want to be this no you need to
understand that there's technicalities
to it and as humans there's there's some
things that you need to understand when
you shouldn't speak and when you should
speak can I answer Mark's question yeah
so in regards to the humility this is
where I would say I agree with Ali
before when he was saying no you tell
your wife no if she's asking for a Lou
tomag and you know you've got to make
money for the rent or you've got to pay
for certain things that are your
responsibility you say no I am not
getting that for you maybe inshallah if
I save for it and whatever you as men
you guys have to also Implement your own
boundaries and you shouldn't feel bad
for doing that because I know that men
do feel bad sometimes you know they feel
like they need to really provide for
their wife they really need to do and
overdo because of social media or
whatever definitely but no no no no you
need to also know your boundaries and if
I had a son I would be telling him the
same my brother I would tell him the
same don't kill yourself to go and you
know get her a Louis a tomag and you
you're not living within your means she
also needs to have that level and
understanding however we do ask for
romance do you know what I mean we where
we are asking for romantic uh you know
nights or walks by the can is always
money which isn't always money and not
all women are are like that bad yeah no
it's true but a lot of the times like um
women do demand materialistic things
right and it's slowly killing men it
really is the expectations for some men
it's killing them the highest suicide
rate is in men even Asian men it's Asian
men can I just add I think the reason um
why first of all men when they attract
women who are very very mentalistic it
could be two things it could be
something that is in their internal
state so they are also materialistic
they've chosen her for looks they've
chose he's also gone for exterior she's
gone for exterior and he's going F
exteria that's number one secondly it
could be a test for him to test his
boundaries a man who's very weak in he's
kind of leadership and he's doesn't know
how to communicate he's being challenged
to to change a weakness within him to
say you know what you know what I
understand where you're coming from but
you know I can't do so and so and as as
a relationship as a married couple it is
expected for there to be compromised and
to understand why she wants it why do
you want a bag why do you want to go on
this holiday can we compromise is it
something that we can put a plan and
work towards it's all about communic a
80% of success in relationship is due to
communication I think um there's more to
it than that communication is key but so
there understanding the communication
people people always talk to each other
but they still B frustrated it's the way
they communicate and it's how stubborn
they are and and all about
the and it's about wanting to reach a
resolution together because it seems
like there's a tug of war me versus you
lack of kindness as well exactly and um
yeah you one thing one thing I remember
sorry to interrupt one thing I remember
listening to I can't remember he's he
he's an expert on marriages or something
along those lines and he said
um ah that's it I almost forgot he said
when PE when couples um married couples
are talking to one another about
something instead of instead of trying
to help one another come to a solution
they're arguing one another's points
instead of help instead of trying to
understand they're saying to reply
remember the
sorry she's already taking it bro but
you know the difference between saying
understand and overand the it's
important to understand what the person
is trying to say to you instead of
arguing or like or instead of taking it
as as an attack it definitely comes as
maturity that when people are talking to
you and they're going and or for example
if you if you were saying something to
me saying we can't get pizza today
instead of me just saying instead of me
saying to you oh that's all right I'm
going to go oh yeah but why like last
time you got like there's no need for
that just just be like be kind like
understand there may be may be an
underlying reason as to why you tell me
that and move on a lot of uh these
situations end up in an argument because
women will tell the man I'm I'm going to
get on to the men here a little bit Yeah
women will tell her husband a woman will
tell her husband I want to go out first
time okay yeah babe all right I'll take
you out second time babe you know I'm
really I want to go out you know I'm
been at home blah blah blah okay
acknowledged no action third time I want
to go
out again no acknowledgement no action
so then it gets to that boiling point
relability as well where she's just like
bro I want to go out you're not taking
me out I've been telling you again and
again again I'm bored I want some
excitement and that's the thing we're
we're not wood women are not pieces of
wood we also have emotions and feelings
and we want excitement and
unfortunately um as much as we we don't
want to acknowledge that social media
can sometimes take a toll it can and it
can influence a wife women are looking
at their surroundings you know and for
standards no not even for standard just
just on a Observatory type of vibe she's
seeing what's happening around her
and that can sometimes affect a woman's
emotions and her her mindset you know
and she'll be like well I want to go out
you're not taking me out and then that
can affect the relationship you know and
I think it's only fair it's only fair
you know you know with men though like
we're not mind readers at the end of the
day and a lot of women don't convey
their feelings properly accurately let
me finish with this their tone you
mentioned tone right I've seen so you
mentioned tone like tonality the way he
speak in you know yeah yeah um yeah so I
think women sometimes lack that sort of
gentle approach they'll straight away go
to like you know having to go at the man
being aggressive this and that obviously
the man's going to react in an
aggressive man you know what I mean
and it's it's hard to we don't a lot of
men don't have the patience well you
have to remember you have to remember if
we're talking about be able to take that
out of a
man a smart and wise woman will be able
to get what she wants from her husband
with with her femininity I'm sure I'm
sure because we are grown men I know men
are six for six believe me when their
wife are feminine let me tell you
something I crumble like you know I
crumble I crumble when my wife is in a
femin energy but man is crumbling I
don't care Jim boxing calisthenics big
biceps I'm on the floor bro yeah why
because because you know why as a man
I'm dealing with masculine energy I'm
come here I got masculine guys I'm going
to the gym everyone's walking about hard
Etc yeah I don't want to come home to
another big Bic you know what I'm trying
to say like so to to to me like when and
I noticed this like for example I can
remember one time I had an arguing with
my wife and I realized I was in the
wrong but just the fact that she wasn't
like how the fact she was just Qui they
didn't say anything BR into that journey
I swear to God brother 20 minutes I
turned to and said I'm sorry cuz you
know why I looked at her and I said I'm
actually I'm wrong and I said to her
look I'm sorry for for for I'm just I
apologize you know why cuz she was in a
feminine energy she wasn't like oh no go
like a ro man that start talking I'm
going to you want to move masculine I
will talk to you masculine so that
disarmed me but today's women they a bit
you know why that's a smart move because
when when she came with Jesus back to
her home to her people yes Allah didn't
tell defend yourself and speak be
silent she had to remain silent and that
is a feminine trait sometimes people
view the silence as a as a of weakness
it is up to me to know am I am I being
silent because I'm I'm scared and I'm
weak or am I using it as a weapon and a
tool of power this this is what the
Western system has taught sisters that
no you go girl you do this that you all
you're doing is putting yourself off us
and you need to understand that and the
the thing is with this is this
expectations like I have e in life which
is I expect the least and I make Dua for
the best anytime there's expectations
get ready for disappointment I'm telling
all of you guys any time you have
expectations get ready for
disappointment in my head I just said to
myself like for example be Mar or
whatever my expectations are low why
some people no BR be ambitious Etc but
me being ambitious is a different story
I'm talking about the woman I'm marrying
expecting the least making Dua for the
best in my head I said I'm okay if my my
wife doesn't need to cook every day she
can if she like if I want her to she
would yeah makes amazing dishes I love
it but even if she I said to myself even
if she cooks two or three days a week
argument sake and if she made me a
simple sandwich in my head I registered
it as I'm happy with that now if I'm
happy with a sandwich what do you think
I'm going to be doing when it's a bloody
lasagna or it's a Biryani or if it's a
roast because my expectations is what
I'm okay with a sandwich but when she
goes the extra level but imagine if I
said now I want a five course meal and
she gives me a sandwich how is it going
to affect my psychology I'm going to be
like what do you see what happens when
you have high expectation now the same
thing happens to our sisters they are
easily influenced they have they're on
their period they go through menopause
they are pregnant there's so many
factors in place yeah and not only that
you guys for what you hear and when you
have these friends who are putting this
stuff in your mind and you're watching
this false reality of these
irresponsible social media couples you
are now unintentionally oppressing us
because you're coming to us with
expectations yeah and what are these
expectations like he said these
expectations are not your symbol like I
just want to go out no man has a problem
taking his wife out zero you are not
coming to us some men you are talking
about exceptions to the rule no it's not
exceptions it say exceptions to the rule
I'm sor if their wife doesn't encourage
them they're fine just being at home
watching Netflix literally some men will
not say okay I'm going to take her out
blah blah blah but my advice to men
would be just pencil in a date once a
month or or once every other month hard
that tapped in the head minimum that
guy's tapped in the head if he doesn't
take his wife out once a month that's
that's that's I think it's so important
for men to at least no but it's
sometimes you're saying that because
alhamd you you have that mindset there
are phen I'm trying to there are some
men who don't do that my sister wasn't
an abusive relationship not abusive
relationship taking that's that's mad
I'm talking about taking her husband
never took her out like once a month no
it was it wasn't like we have to save
money there's no such and some people
are like that they have that mindset
they even used to compare oh like her
husband used to say oh why are you um
why does your sister spend her and
husband go out and spend no that's
that's a stingy man the prophet actually
warned against there was a woman who
came no no no but the thing is this is a
bad Carib because at the end of the day
he's a stingy man but we speak for every
and we know and we know from Islam a
woman can go to her husband's pocket if
he's stingy he doesn't give she has a
right to go and get money out because
this is her right so this kind of men I
don't know is this is this please tell
me like this
100% 100% Al
really
do use use the mic use the mic if you're
going to say you can't hear you so you
guys forgot to mention that there
there's this problem where you know when
when Brothers like let's say your
husband goes out and does things for you
um he'll he'll remind you like in in an
argument I've done this for you I've
done that for you why though why though
this
is Sister Sister okay if you okay I get
it I get it if you don't what a woman
known for what a woman known for and we
have a clear get it if you don't feel
appreciated just tell her just tell I
don't feel appreciated you know Sister
Lucky why do we feel unappreciated we
know let's be honest when women get
angry when they get upset when they're
on their period they say things they
don't mean but to us we don't register
that they don't mean you are a stingy
guy you I've never seen any good from
you and you're thinking and the woman do
they say that or am I lying please be
honest I do women what I would add to
that do wom say things I would what I
would say is let's say a woman's had an
argument yeah with her man or a
disagreement or something like that
usually and tell me if I'm if you guys
experienced it
but be with your own sisters so you know
one second stop uh so yeah for for me in
a nutal I think like my eil in life is
basically expecting the least and making
Dua for the best uh because a lot of the
times what happens is a lot of people go
into marriages and many things with high
expectations and if you have high
expectations be ready for disappointment
so to me I expect the least and I make
Dua for the best so I'll say oh Allah
for example I'm happy with my my wife
making a sandwich totally happy I'm okay
with a sandwich I'm just happy with that
yeah if I have a good woman I'm not
going to complain about Bloody sandwich
bro it's good you get what I'm trying to
say but I can make Dua and be like Oh
Allah I would love in my head you get
I'm giv an example so to me I'm happy
with the sandwich now if it's the other
way around and I'm like I expect the
lasagna and I get a sandwich I'm unhappy
I'm disappointed so sometimes with
sisters you need to understand something
Allah has created you guys in a very
unique way if you think about it why has
Allah
in the Quran hasn't gone into details
what you're going to get in in Jen have
you ever wondered that cuz to us is very
simple Allah says and it gives a very
brief detailed description of how
they're going to look and we get excited
and guess I cannot wait to go Jenna very
specific because we know what we want
direct to the point with you guys when
you have a discussion and you want to
ask your friend what time we're meeting
you start talking about like the moon
and then you go to like the Galaxy and
then you go to like a boat and and then
and then you come to oh what time we
meeting cuz your brains are wide like
that that because you guys tend to talk
more than we do it's not a bad thing
that's how you're wired so the thing is
when you guys have this false reality in
in your head and you're watching social
media couples you're watching this
couple they're going in Holiday they're
doing this and the expectations are
increasing and increasing it makes us
feel in gratitude when we have when
there is an argument and we are made to
feel oh you're like this or I've never
seen any good from you you're always
this this and as men which was mentioned
sister Perina is that of course we're
going to now talk about the fa that we
do because Quran ay very clearly says do
not render your good deeds by reminding
people this ay doesn't fit you because
we are outright being told that we are
useless individuals and as a man your
love language is love romance Etc to us
is respect you are outright
disrespecting Us by seeing look what he
does or comparing us to other husbands
or making us feel that we're not good
enough so do you see where we come from
when we are made to feel like that and
your expectations are so high I please
anas tell me why you disagree with me no
no finish finish okay so that show your
expectations are so high and sometimes I
believe women can't pinpoint what they
really want am I wrong to say that that
they do not know what they want there's
so many things am I please correct me I
love to be corrected I feel as if like
in your psychology you genuinely do not
know what you want you can't put your
finger on but in a man in a man and
sometimes in
general so here has one and a half
minutes your time St so firstly like
point I want to meet that even in
disagreements you're supposed to be uh
somewhat of respect meaning you don't
talk like a donkey you don't talk with
rais voices as the Quran States and the
other thing is that during the prophet's
time it's like he went a whole month
without his wives I don't know if you
know this meaning wives were asking the
prophet which he couldn't provide
meaning Prophet chose himself he had two
choices to live like a king or the CH
that could po life now does this does
this mean that our women folks shouldn't
you know yearn this m materialism to a
certain extent yes and no to the
extravagance of the persons the husbands
or the the men from Community not having
uh say if there's pocket type are you to
a woman of understanding a woman of
intellect despite her feeling just
because we might we can't use our
experiences or the biology of us saying
that you can't use an excuse meaning we
have to fight with an us to say that
despite this I'm still going to say this
meaning for example if your husb if you
know your rent is ,000 do you really
expect your husband to buy a 1,000 gold
watch you shouldn't be doing that
meaning that you should always try to
see both sides of the party meaning that
for example see when the prophet went
away that was he he he he didn't go away
like that there was some time again and
again again and again with the prophet
and wives they they show the side and
after they revealed look you can either
leave the prophet or you can CH or you
can choose or you can choose the this U
the life of the here after with
benefiting this
yes so it says oh Prophet say to your
wives if you intend to have the pleasure
of the worldly life and it in its charm
then come on and I shall give you some
stuff and release you in a handsome
fashion so the prophet's being told to
them because they were obviously um
causing a bit of difficulty for the
prophet but if you intend to gain the
pleasure of Allah and his messenger and
the betterment of the Hereafter then
Allah has prepared a great reward for
those who are good in their deeds oh
wives of the Prophet whoever from you
will commit this is going into the other
issue but here Allah mention which said
something very profound is that this and
all this glamour yeah or the if your
husband cannot give you that there are
women that are losing their good
husbands and the that he's going to help
her achieve at the cost of the D is the
key here lastly I wanted to say that is
look there some some from a cultural
standpoint or from whatever standpoint
you are some men yeah some men believe
that you know me doing the bare minimum
and the bare minimum means provide
protect and that's it no affection No
Love No Mercy no nothing and they expect
this no as a husband you have to have
everything just because you're tied from
work or just because you're this or just
because you're that or I've had a fight
or I've had this no no what you have to
understand is rights and
responsibilities and a man as a man
you're supposed to be vision for for
this life and for the next 5 years 10
years 15 years on a daily basis how am I
supposed to act with the people around
me you just doing the bare minimum as
thinking a matal man and that doesn't
mean the term of a matal man yes because
we can't keep on saying oh blaming the
west and this and as Muslims we're the
we're the leaders meaning not just
leaders within our homes but in the
community as a worldwide for non-muslims
and Muslims alike that's that's that's
very important you can't just keep on
blaming on the west the West this
colonialism I'm not I'm not I'm not
saying
that last words I'm not saying
colonialism and the other things didn't
play a part they still play a part they
have played a part even in gen Z My
Generation you still play A Part yeah
that's
on um I think you uh
brother brother anas made a very very
good point um but going back to um
Brother Ali um you kind of I I I don't
maybe I didn't understand your point but
you said that oh that when it's a man
he's saying well I've done this and I've
done this it's not the same as when
woman does it how is that different what
do you mean when when a when a man when
a woman says oh I did this for you and I
did that but when a man does it it's not
the same no I never said that I said for
example that for examp for example if
our wives we look when we go and work to
us we see that as a form of love
language we're seeing we're going out
there we can do works that can we can
die in the process we are more actually
we're more prone to dying because of
anything an alteration on the road do
you get it we men we have lethal Force
like for example stud giving child birth
as well sorry there's more risk men die
no no no it's irrelevant she can die
like with but but do you see you see
what this goes down to now it goes for a
tip for tap I never said I never said a
woman doesn't we know for example if a
woman dies given birth she's a Mart the
point I'm saying is we are more prone to
die be in the workplace be in
altercation be it protecting you guys
we're full full-time bodyguards by the
way if a comes if a thief comes breaking
the house best believe my wife is going
to say listen bounce get out please
please please go s this and guess what
if I die in the process you know she she
could get married again you CH toe so
the you w think twice you won't think
twice about doing that no no bro it's in
our blood love it man dying for it's all
day every day so what I'm saying is in a
nutshell is that when our wives when we
go and work and our work is is seen as
you just have to what you mean I just
have to I do it because I love you and I
work for you and when you come and tell
us oh but you're stingy or you're and if
he's not I'm seeing if he's not when
your words are a bit harsh and you say
that of course a man's going to remind
you and say but I work for our family I
do this and that he reminds because he's
been now this ingratitude that's coming
from the wife so he's reminding the fa
of
that mindset this is the the type of
women you're speaking about have a
specific mindset okay those specific
type of women they need to be dealt with
in a very very different way and
psychologists a lot of therapists they
have a they have a tactic they so
basically sorry we would like to know
what is that t so obviously I'm not like
that professional in that sense but
there's they speak there's a specific
tactic with women who who have that kind
of personality you see but but but but a
lot women have this it's a very common
it's a common cuz the prophet said he
went to the Hellfire and he saw a
majority of his inhabitants women and
they said why is it because they're
ungrateful like doing to Allah they said
no they they are doing it yes they're
doing it to to their husbands so the
prophet also gave a solution does it as
well it's the same on him so if it it is
he he spoke about who is more prone to
do it we're looking at what the prophet
wasam said we know for example woman
look we have the power of talak yeah
okay that is the reason because Allah
has created you guys in in a way where
you're emotional sometimes you say
things you don't mean understandable you
guys initiate divorce more than we do
that's why Allah's given a talak to us
and also Allah has kept us in check by
giving us three options of tal and if
you look at IM he says the reason why it
was limited to three is because thei men
used to abuse their wives what they
would do is they'll say tal the woman
would go and they say I'll take you back
and they would do this without a limit
so you're not allowing her to move on
with her
life so Allah stipulated to three
meaning after the third one brother that
woman has rights to go get married
without you so that talak is actually
there to protect you so what I'm seeing
is from the Dynamics there's certain
things you are prone to do one of the
things is what being in grateful to your
husband what did the prophet sallam say
the husband will be good if they see one
bad what did they say I've seen no good
in you that is the CR I just wanted to
mention one last thing about when a
woman doesn't um when she says when she
says oh I want I want this and I want
that I think there's nothing wrong with
a man communicating what he wants from
his wife and what a woman wants from her
husband it's a at the end of the day it
goes back to negotiation a man can tell
his wife oh you know what um I like for
example I like you to do your nails for
example or I like you it doesn't mean
that oh my God why you like this and why
do you expect this from me and why do
you it's sometimes we like to see our
husbands do specific things for us but
it doesn't mean that it's compulsory it
doesn't mean we're forcing them it
doesn't mean it's about negotiation at
the end of the day because there's
Harmony it's a it's home if if there's
that tug of war then what's the point of
the relationship anyway you know the the
problem with like negotiations and um
these sorts of discussions right who's
more prone to being like more emotional
the man or the woman so what I'm saying
is when a man wants to communicate
something to his wife that knows it's
going to be quite like you know a
debatable topic he's just going to not
talk about it because he knows it's
going to cause issues in the household
do you know what I mean make before we
move on from that point I just want to
make a point of um the prophet
ibraim when he went to go and visit his
son I believe it's is yeah yeah and he
knocked on his son's door and the wife
was just complaining about everything
complaining about the house complaining
about everything and he left the message
and he said to to the wife when your
husband gets home tell him to change the
Gate of the door yeah tell him to change
the the the the front no the gate the
Gate of the door so when he came when
his son came back she gave him the
message which meant obviously change
this woman she's not she's divorced her
so when ibraim came back he found that
ishak had made got a different wife and
she was grateful she was very grateful
and he said please keep the door you
know keep this gate of your home now I
think this is a good reminder for men if
your wife is severely
ungrateful change the Gate of your door
what are we forcing this thing and
killing
ourselves many examples in our dean of
situations where you can leave a woman
if she's just ungrateful and wants the
world from you let her go and find uh uh
Zacharia from down the road and see if
she it gets more tricky when there's
kids involved and there's you know
culture I don't believe I don't believe
think it's more tough I don't believe in
that I'm so sorry I believe that if two
parents are not happy it's more
detrimental to the children I of course
we can fight for our kids and of course
we can you know be and try and be
patient and saber yeah I I agree but
when there's a woman and she's actually
above the type of woman Ali is trying to
describe here you leave that woman but
the women that we're talking about the
women that just want a date once in a
while this is something that's why
that's why I was shocked to be like
there are men that doing this men some
men yeah I know a lot of men they're
raised in the hood they're raised in the
areas they nobody has taught them
romance a lot of them don't know how to
be a romantic husband or know how to be
soft with their we had we had an episode
with sister Rob about that basically
they told us how to be like the love
language romance expressing your love we
had a whole episode a lot of men just
think straightforward and I get thata
you but but they need to understand that
actually when you now get married and
this is why I say a lot of people should
not be getting married until they have
that sort of training yes you need to
have pre-marriage counseling you need to
be spoken to you need to understand the
basics and this is why the bitter truth
show is really good because at at least
you guys can hear this before you get
into marriage you cannot just think
you're getting into this marriage and oh
this is going to be my wife and I'm
going to chill no this is not that you
need to be romantic very very key like
this is you have to
otherwise yeah
um um so I was going to make the point
of you know where I was talking about
there's some men who will remind their
wives of oh I did this for you and then
they'll go to the point of oh you
wouldn't have this if it wasn't because
of me and they make them feel so so low
and most of the times these women don't
work and they don't have their own
income coming on coming in and they're
completely relying on their husband and
he knows this and he uses this as a
leverage over her um to say to say look
you would have have this if it wasn't if
it wasn't because of me or but no like
you she wouldn't have that if it wasn't
cuz Allah gave you that Pro provision to
be able to provide for her you know cuz
I seen a lot of like Buddhas say like um
say that you know you know everything
like I've given everything my wife has
I've given it to her no like Allah has
given that to you Allah has given you
the ability to provide for your
wife yeah no no cuz there's a especially
like in our communi there's a lot of
women like sorry I was going to say
especially like in our community there's
a lot of women like who will go to their
husband words are so dangerous I'm going
to come to and by Sister you have so
much amazing contributions and don't
about this wouldn't have done that to
his wies oh I provided you and I did
this and I did that he wouldn't have
done that nether done that because they
do that I'll tell
you tells his woman every time I do oh
you are here because of me I made you
that is point blank Financial abuse it
is emotional abuse it is abuse you as a
husand hband should never open your or
fix your lips to turn to your wife and
say I've made you you're closed because
of me you are now abusing that power
that's it that's iing Woman as a woman
if you're suffering from this I suggest
you do have a divorce and if you've
got H me out okay finish your sentence
listen I'm the B product of that I'm a
child from that and I swear it's so
cruel to see two parents fighting and
arguing all the time thought like
couldn't they separate already and then
have like the kids would have it easier
you understand it's it's not fair on the
child forget okay this is this is this
is the reason why um I'll be very Brown
to the point this is why men are leaders
what you guys said a couple of and by
the way look may Allah bless you guys
well I appreciate what you're saying Etc
we here to talk about these matters if
I'm wrong I'll put my hand up and say
I'm wrong and tell me if I'm wrong we've
saw some very we said some very
dangerous stuff here and this is
irresponsible Behavior if even if it
came from me to mention the word oh if
this happens divorce this is such a
dangerous statement what I mean is not
when you're not grateful I know I know
sister about the gate thing I know I
know I know but what I'm saying I know I
know I know but even when sister said
which I I kind of agree where like you
know if she's been ungrateful even then
the word divorce we need to be very
careful you know why I how many couples
are watching this and you know what
they're going to do do this they get
something for example terminologies they
don't even know what it means what does
do you mean by that Financial abuse what
do you mean by that you're controlling
what do you mean by that so what happens
is we have people who apply it to theel
so what they say is Okay so we've said
some stuff there's a sister watching
this who's had an arguing with her
husband and her husband why she's had an
argu with her husband is because she
keeps going to a husband and comparing
him to others and the husband has to
remind them and say listen but we're not
talking about that she never spoke about
that she spoke about an extreme case of
men who spit back what they do into
Woman face I'm not saying that you
should divorce because of however it
is an
emal Al you're scared of these words
we're not taking it out of context
you're being scared of the word the word
abuse sometimes we can abuse our power
it doesn't mean it's oh this major thing
no if if you are spitting back what you
do for your wife on a regular basis or I
pay for this oh I do this and the same
for women I'm not saying it's not the
same for women I'm saying the same
that's why I use the example of the
Prophet
ibraahim but if a man is doing this
constantly in his wife's face that is
emotional abuse how is the woman meant
to feel if he's always saying to
her I I provide your lifestyle I get
your one second guys is your
responsility guys that's what I'm saying
let's bring Clarity to the matter so we
understand what we're talking about
is it emotional abuse when he says that
if he's doing I Believe by
Def do we accept that I I I accept that
as well is it emotional abuse when she
goes to her husband and says this person
does that you are stingy you don't do
nothing is that em she say over and over
again one second if she is making a film
like crap because of her expectations of
Instagram is that emotional abuse good
who did verbal and emotional abuse who
did the emotional abuse start from if it
started from the woman's side where
remember we talked what do women want if
she's had this Instagram she's watching
all these expectations then taking on a
husband who's working hard but can't
afford the stuff that she wants and then
he's been told now you don't do this you
don't do that where is the emotional
abuse stem from but now you've created a
scenario you created a relationship
scenario this person you know why you
know why it's the mirror because we're
talking gen you know how many people are
going to take that gen apply to this
specific household and no that's our
problem that's our problem
that's our problem sister let me tell
you why let me just
finish himself says that
itself which means that even the Quran
itself can misguide people and it can
guide people but it is depend it depends
on the person if he's a f so what we
need to go back to is we need to PR not
practice and um not practice the traits
of a which is not applying Allah's rules
so anyone understand anything there are
millions of people who watch this and
some of them will take the good there's
a verse that in the Quran that
says I'm not going to say that
everything we said in the show is 100%
right but I anyone who's watching this
and I'm saying it from the depths of my
heart and from someone who's been
searching for so many years do your
research not everything we say on this
show is 100% just because some people
have authority just because someone is a
mentor just because someone's a coach it
doesn't mean that their word is Gospel
do your research why because Allah will
guide you that is fundamental and you
know do your research on what Financial
abuse means what narcissist means and
don't apply and say oh you know what
just because you know what yeah you want
some Because by the way there's a rearch
that says that we all can um act
narcissistically like we can so narcism
and just because I for example just
because someone looks in a mirror one of
the traits is that a narcissist looks in
a mirror lot just because someone has
this little tra doesn't he's a
narcissist you cannot put a judgment
because Allah
says Allah alone is you know is going to
do that is going to has the authority to
have that judgment a man today can
commit Zena tomorrow he's good to his
parents the day after he reads Quran the
day after he gives sodak the day after
he beats a man up and then the the day
after he's good to his wife and the day
after he says sorry how are you going to
judge that person you're not going to be
able to do that no I I understand that
but the point here is it still stands
the thing is we have a responsibility
here as people are watching this that we
clarify certain things because at the
end of the day the prophet was walking
with his wife and he he he had there two
companions that saw him he went to them
this is the messenger of Allah he went
to them and said by this is my wife he
messenger of Allah of course we didn't
that anyway he said Shan runs through
the veins of Adam so the point is here
what we're seeing is somebody can easily
watch this take this argument that we're
seeing and apply it to their marriage
and say see they're talking whoa whoa
whoa rewind rewind we're talking about
that's what I was like let's break it
down because our words have consequences
very very important that's why I'm so
stuck on this to get this out of the way
because I know this can break marriages
and I know this show is the opposite so
if I can just make this way without
without being cut please yeah the point
is this is that when it comes to issues
we need to clarify because I said if the
wife is the one who is comparing him and
making him feel like crap by the way
yeah and by the way this is a very big
phenomena happening in the community a
lot of Muslim women are oppressing their
wives I mean their husbands in a very
very bad way so now because we have this
pandemic yeah so for example if he was
living at a time where men were the
culprit of domestic abuse yeah then it
would be unjust for me to brush it aside
I be like no this is a focal point
because it's happening a lot so now in
this era when we're talking about this I
have to break it down and say if a woman
is saying that to her husband has she
initiated the abuse yes good now if the
husband then comes and says well but do
I not buy you clothes look look at the
tone not hey I buy you clothes I own you
no no no but do I not buy you clothes
but do I not work hard for our family
I'm saving up for a holiday yeah is that
does that apply to that man no it
doed then that's
fine is trying to
clear
clarify but I was talking about if the
the man is conly like she comes to him
and she she asks hey can I now he's the
aggressor you see now in this instance
he's the aggressor because now he's not
even doing the basic BR she wants to
take it's crazy to me that a woman a man
doesn't take his wife out I I'm GoBack I
I I'm find it very hard to believe could
even need some money like let's say need
some money he has to protect and provide
for I'm that's what I'm saying like this
that's what I'm saying like
um it's especially like within our
community like if a if a if a wife who's
not working goes to her husband and says
hey like I need some new clothes can can
you give me some money like he he'll be
like no like I disagree with that say no
they question it they question it and
they do it in a des way he'd be like if
you need like ID for like clothes or
something the man will be like oh but
why do you need that that's that's a
general that's that's generally how it
is say it's gen I
guess I guess what I'm saying is very
subjective because I've seen it yeah
I've seen it too i' the man is never I
wouldn't say never but the man often
isn't willing to just give 100 quid here
and there for the for his misses to get
clothes he'll question it quite a bit
even 100 sometimes even 20 like he
question sorry Sor seen that I'm so
sorry yeah look if if there like again
we have to put it into context and there
has to be a balance if a man says no not
it's not just cuz he's saying no if he's
saying I can't give you 100 quid just to
go and waste it on clothes you have to
understand as a woman as well this is
your household it's your
economy point and his money is your
money yeah so if he that doesn't stand
that that his money is her money is is
actually out of context if he's unable
to give that's that's a different story
what the sister was saying is when the
man has the facilities the finances and
then he says no even refuse him when he
when he says like uh oh what you need it
for like you don't need this even if he
still gives it the way he speaks his
tone like he needs to explain properly
that's but I've seen that very common
it's very that is true during a dating
phase or whatever you know when you're
like thinking is this person to marry
he'll be so willing to give money let's
go to fancy places when they're actually
married he's not willing to do the
finances to facilitate the I think
generation though that's unbelievable to
me man you know what way you know what
I'm talking about I think I've seen that
more in the older generation because
like ter don't work and sorry we one and
a half minutes start I don't need one
and a half minutes but all no all I
wanted to say this is from when we
talking about co-parent I've been
sitting there for so long um I just
wanted to mention the difference I think
some parents have and I've witnessed
this firsthand personally so I I think I
know what I'm talking about um certain
parents who don't want to break up for
their children's sake do do more harm to
their children because not only do you
see the fighting side of what goes on
whether it be physical or verbal when
they finally break up and they leave
each other there's they're not
co-parenting they want I'm having a
child today no you're not yeah you're
doing this no you're not like oh are you
taking him swimming like no not today a
and then you got arguments whereas if
you are mature about it yeah and you
don't stay with each other for the sake
of the kids when in reality for the sake
of the kids actually makes the life of
the kids more difficult in the future
you should actually sit down with one
another and think about what is best for
yourself and for the other person
because not not enough that people
actually think about themselves when
when in a uh relationship when they have
kids if you look after yourself and you
look after your wife and you look after
that relationship you will be able to be
stronger for your children so if say you
do end up break or you do end up losing
feelings for your wife or your husband
and say you need to sit down with one
another and actually go through the
reasons why and you can't fix it then
split up agree to co-parent and do
things properly because otherwise you
are going to make your children's life
hell I absolutely promise you can we
have some soltion that's all that's all
I wanted to say bless you we've got
about 10 15 minutes on this episode can
we just have some solutions now what
advice would you give to Young sisters
who are watching this who may have high
expectations of what they want in a man
um what would you say that for example
should we start with the brothers maybe
Brothers given advice to sisters because
we're men in it what what would you say
to Young sisters who were looking to get
married and they have this high
expectations as men to our sisters you
know and then our sisters to our
brothers you know that what woman look
for so we can educate oursel inshallah
what would you say to imagine a young
sister who looking get mad I'd say I'd
say if you if you look if you got
expectations which are high that's
completely normal you can have it if you
want but then you have to bring
something to the table as well I don't
like using this
terminology um like they say high value
man high value woman if you're looking
for a high value man you yourself have
to be a high value woman I if your man's
going to provide for you like Financial
Security everything yeah you need to be
able to clean cook look after the kids
you still got your right to St
islamically but you have to put your
effort into and I've seen it maybe you
guys are different but very common for
me women aren't prepared to like look
after the household look after the
children a lot of them just want to go
out do this and that go food Instagram
all of that that's just my personal
experience so if you're looking for a
high value man are you yourself a high
value woman yes that's right
yeah so so firstly I wanted to say in
terms of what sister Amir said in terms
of the in terms of what the prophet
Abraham said to his sons and similarly
om I think he said the same thing to his
son as well you know take my opinion
divorce your wife these are case back
these situations where it was granted
only them because what our parents do is
like they have that thing within our
saying you know the authority so it's a
bit you have to be careful when you say
this stuff because it's like it's a case
by case situation secondly I like to say
is that a lot of people a lot of
youngsters My Generation they don't know
themselves okay they don't they don't
know themselves meaning they don't know
what they really want or what they want
or they're filtered by these these
external factors where actually it clubs
their their mental faculties maybe
wanting more or maybe wanting less and
also I wanted to say was that look in
terms of the the dean there was a man
who came to the came to and to all the
people was I have this notion yet where
people was strong he was this strong he
didn't take any heat no because these
people there some people My Generation
specifically they said I I want to be
this matal man but if you there was a
man who went to omab he knocked at his
door he was like he could hear some
voices what happened was that the man
went back and then om opened the door
back again he was like he's like brother
what why did you know what I do and then
om was like he said what do you want the
was like I came to your door because my
wife was giving me Slack my wife was
saying this I was
complaining you know he used to carry a
stick in the marketplace just to make
sure people would stay in line he used
to he used to be in the mosque and
people the people used to complain
saying that you know Allah I'll put all
my Allah and Allah will bless me with
both he he used to be the man who
carries sticks when he was at home he
said you know my wife she complains I'm
not going to leave her because she
starts complaining or this or that so
it's very important knowing yourself
what you can handle and what you cannot
handle before marriage don't think
because a lot this it's a disgusting
notion that our Dean is just this fil
factor of like um my morning routine no
it's not a morning routine it's not the
it's not a way of life it's the way of
life look the way of life simly like
other religions saying oh no but why
this no it's the way of life because why
is that especially in my generation and
the generations you could say
Millennials they feel that because of
the movies it clogs their brain saying
that they don't think years time 3 years
Time 5 years time and they don't plan
out their life expecting Jenna
everything you do in life has to be some
sort of roote to Jenna and if you have
anything clogging that you need to take
it away reassess your situation no
matter in the dean your your money your
Fame no matter how you want to get to
Jenna you need to actualize it even your
marriage meaning that marriage is a
major thing you can either Enter Hell or
Heaven that's
what
uh Michel and then we going go
to I've gone blank
um it's okay I think it's thatting on
the spot um uh for the for the sisters
that want to get married to a man and
they have high standards we spoke about
this on a previous episode uh it's okay
to have high standards yeah that's
absolutely fine and for the man that has
the means to provide that that's even
better um I think humbleness is a big
thing for me and I think we've already
repeated this like two or three times if
you can maintain humbleness yeah you
will be able to like I don't know
whether this is a flex or not probably
is but you'll be able to attract a lot
of men towards you if you are humble
whether they're rich or not humbleness
is says a lot about your personality so
that's what that's that's that's what I
have to say what advice would you give
to young men watching this um you know
to young women huh do you say young
women uh young men or you can speak to
your Co it's up to you like you know if
you want to is I what I would say is yes
to the to the to the women before you
even think about like finding a man what
you want in a man is know your rights in
Islam know your rights in Islam and you
know find out who you are you need to
know who you like like the brother was
saying you need to know who you are what
you want from Life what your purpose is
in life build your connection with Allah
before you even think about what I want
in mind and automatically
automatically the right man will come
into your life you won't even like have
to work too hard like I want this I want
that work on yourself work on yourself
that's all I will
say
Parina um well I was going to say by the
way um but to add to that I would
say men need to know their rights and
women need to know their rights in a mar
to say a couple and you both have to
make sure you talk about it you put
everything to the table what will I not
tolerate what will I tolerate both sides
it's like a mutual thing and
compatibility is also like a massive
thing like you hear like you've got
someone who's got deed but you don't
like doing anything together like going
out for a walk oh no I just I don't like
walks when get tired do you get what I
mean you need compatibility as well as
know your rights man knowing your rights
putting all your cards on the table
before you realize the
one thank you now so yes it com to
sister having high expectations in a man
um it depends if it's materialistic
expectation that is something that is a
dunia progress and that can be done over
time in its time um but that shouldn't
be the priority I think the priority
should be the the values like I
mentioned in the beginning of the
episode which is core values and I know
a lot of brothers said oh you know what
women say that they want these things
but realistically they don't um
um and yeah but those are the
fundamentals but are men actually
practicing these things are women
actually practicing these things for
them to attract that kind of man Allah
says which means if you're a you will
attract a if you're you're going to get
it's it's it's rocket science so if you
want if you want someone who's going to
be your person on on this journey of the
dun you have to embody the
that you want the person like the man
that you want to be with it it it it's
just it is what it is and the man is
well he can't say you know I want this I
want that and he's not he's like he's
not that person that he wants that woman
um also another thing is that before you
get married is that you have to know you
and your partner or the person you're
going to get married what is my what is
our purpose in life together like what
are we walking towards how are we going
to benefit the umah how what is our
message and when you have a shared goal
you are able to walk like to to drive
together and sail together on that
Journey it becomes much more fun becomes
much more exciting we even get excited
for the challenges that come our way
like now when me and my husband we get
challenges on the on the way and it's
like hard and sometimes it's painful and
sometimes it is sleepless nights and
sometimes it is days of crying but
there's so much Beauty and there's so
much essence of rahma and Ma and keeping
that respect I think it's a balance you
know
and yeah so I just think that it's about
the values it's about the values
practicing them not saying oh yeah I
want a man who's patient I want this and
this and this and then you're not even
doing anything about your anger issues
you're not doing you're not taking
courses about your how to um you know
communicate by the way I was the worst
Communicator in the
world I was the worst and I lost a lot
of relationships and a lot of
friendships because of my communication
because I wasn't able to be open because
I wasn't able to express myself but
guess what I was like you know what I'm
not going to let that stop me I took
courses I listen to so many different
people I listen to people in the west I
listen to M and it has grounded me and
it's actually in fact surprisingly
enough that I wasn't going to come today
to the show because my husband had kind
of precautions about it but I made it
and I convinced him and he came with me
accompanied me with so much love and he
supported me so a wise woman can
actually get what she wants from her man
in the right way and in the most smart
way because it is possible I think shaan
just tries to come and say oh you know
it's you you can't do that and this and
this and this be aware that shatan is on
is in between
whether which is the humans who try to
separate um listening to false
information oh if he does this and
drawing conclusions I think gaining a a
a a very clear understanding and
negotiating and when we have a
problem it's me and you in this contract
it's not my mom it's not my dad it's not
my friend who went on a holiday it's not
that and there's nothing wrong with
wanting specific things oh baby I want I
want a holiday I want this but then
there's compromise there's ground rules
there's ways of doing it you know so I
think I think that's it if anything
comes up then but and
then yeah so I mentioned the bat before
and I would love to have a bat and I
want that for myself I don't want that
for my man so what I'm trying to say
is what I'm trying to say is you said
before about being high value yourself
to find to have a high value man like I
would I want to have a Bo I want a man
that's loving I want a man that's a
leader I want a man that's
God-fearing I want
these I want these I would expect him to
be on like a nice like the same level he
have like a fast Mustang or something
part to you know I'd want him to like
sit Synergy with me if you get what I'm
saying no there's nothing wrong with
that well I'll be honest with you and
you never know we might insh find
you honest you the reason why I I'll be
honest I find it like very I don't know
what the word to use but it's like cute
in the sense where like M that's your
dream you want you want somebody dreams
are very good dreams are very good if
there if there's a brother out there who
lik sailing catching fishes inshallah
inshallah yes no problem marry contact
the S contact the sister's father inah
and yes that's you might do any on a
boat yeah me well you can rent it yeah
no problem maybe yeah
well yeah well and if you do call us to
the boat
in my point is why I want a boat is
because I've
heal I had my problems and I realized
you know what I love boats I love the
sea I love the water I'm no honestly
I've healed myself I've had to like look
into that closet find the that's find I
want my man to have the same thing
sister the thing is with this because
the thing is like some people like some
for some people it's being alone in a
forest like some people different people
no no I'm being honest people have like
some people they find it like funny
because it's it's unheard like you're
fixing on B but to you that means a lot
for some people it can be like I don't
know I want to go to I just want to be
in the car well I just want to it's for
different people it means different
things it has significance for you and
there is absolutely nothing wrong it
brings you peace as exactly thece come
on bro like it's growing it's growing on
me I might take me and my wife going the
boat going the boat no it's it's it
might be animals the birds there you go
may Allah bless you with the husband in
yes and that's unique how many
s
go point is is the healing thing I've
healed so if you're looking for someone
you have to find them on the same level
as you they have to have healed
themselves and to to the guys out there
you need to do the healing to the girls
out there you need need to do the
healing don't don't expect likeone a
Gucci bag that's a Gucci bag is not
going to heal that nice shoes are not
going to heal that never exactly may
Allah bless you yes s bless you we're
going to wrap up um so yeah I I was
going to say a lot of things but so much
has been said yeah the boat is
definitely in my head so I'm going to be
on a yacht in the by I'm joking but um
so for me I would definitely say for the
men out there if you are in a marriage
and your wife is continually asking you
for dates or whatever just pencil it in
make time because what it is for women
is when you aren't given that action it
just it translates to us as we you do
not value US in that way or you do not
value US enough to make that time for
what we believe is important for the
relationship so it's very important to
take time for what you have like you you
said a contract you've made that
contract of Life of marriage so you need
to work on that both of you together you
know marriage is something that we have
to work on nourish water you know so it
can grow and and become very beautiful
and I'm not saying it's this fairy tale
thing of course there's ups and downs
and I'm not telling women out here
to divorce their husbands because he
won't buy you a Ferrari or a Lamborghini
or a uh you know these material things
no this is not what we're saying yeah I
just wanted to very be clear on that
because I'm not an advocate of you know
I believe that when you get married
anything good comes with trials and
tribulations and when Allah loves you he
tests you so if you're in a marriage and
there's it's testing and it's there's
trials there's challenges sa you have to
be patient in these situations however
there are the extremes that were said
here of women who are ungrateful and
overly you know demanding of things not
even thinking for a second of how this
has an effect on her husband or the man
vice versa of How It's not having effect
how this is affecting his wife however
we just have to be fair and balanced you
know and
honestly moms dads out there before you
send your beautiful children out into
marriage please train them speak to them
about these things you know take them to
to Bangladesh Pakistan Rwanda wherever
to to teach them humility so they can
really see what this dun is about and
it's not just cars fashioned Glam take
them to the cemetery if they have to as
a reminder to bring them back down to
earth yeah because it's it's not all
about the glits and Glamour and not
Everything That Glitters Is Gold okay so
just yeah it's it's an illusion it's
it's all part of that but yeah working
on yourself is very important taking
accountability understanding one another
and doing that work to to to have this
solid foundation and inshallah marriages
will keep in one TX I was just say one
one thing I need to wrap up guys I was
gonna say a strong family unit means a
strong um exactly it's it's true um and
guys inal you heard from the sisters
what they want in a man um and we have
talked about the extremes you know make
sure that balance we don't go overboard
uh because otherwise you could hit a
wall and realize that SP all those
stands are going to drop at one point
when you realize you know your ages
getting older Etc so yeah in a ni show
you've heard of it inshallah uh and yeah
it's just from us like I said that Allah
the Quran tells the prophet's wives if
you want the d you can have the D but
the is better inshah that we work and
we're jna driven When we married we
think about Jenna if we do that our
lives will be better and different
inshallah uh till next time so after
this episode or maybe the episode might
come before is we've got a whole episode
of how uh the sisters were basically
teaching us how to be with our wives
Love Languages we literally was such a
good episode I recommend all the
brothers to watch how to express your
love to your wives uh when you come home
home we talked about it was so good I
learned so much from it so watch that
episode so as men we educate ourself to
know how to communicate to our wives and
understand their Love Languages as well
which is very fundamental because their
emotional being they they they they fall
for what they hear just tell them Beau
like well I be honest like like I've
said this in the other episode actually
like I'll be honest say that like when
in the morning you know everyone looks
terrible in the morning yeah okay but to
me like I'll be honest my wife walks in
the door I'll just be like yo look at
that painting yeah like like and and
look even and me alhamd I know like to
me she is in my eyes but even for some
brothers if you don't deem your wife to
be a p whatever you guys want to call in
today's day see it even if that's what
allowed White Lies it makes them feel
good you lose nothing you lose nothing
but anyway that's for the other episode
next time for the bit of Truth it is it
is it is but it's a beautiful lie uh
till next
time the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masid for
the take of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tala tells us that our books will be
given and every little at and weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masid oh Allah
you helped you gave to it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if youve
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards